live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions
it's the Dave Ramsey show where that is
dumb
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice
I'm tafe Ramsey your host this is your
show the phone numbers triple 8 8 2 5 5
2 2 5 note to self don't open up Twitter
right before you go on the air for a new
hour of the show because I enter the
show laughing at this guy posting his
bass boat for sale add fifty six
thousand dollars or best offer need gone
as soon as possible only 35 hours on it
covered and stored inside mercury 250
pro excess engine I'm selling it because
it was purchased without the proper
consent of loving wife apparently do
whatever the f you want to do doesn't
mean what I thought yeah you gotta learn
to speak wife son okay there you go
just in case you were wondering you know
that is a funny way to bring up a real
solid financial principle here's a solid
financial principle all the data points
that we have with millionaires tell us
that the millionaires that are married
have good communication lines and
agreement agreed value systems with
their spouses very few millionaires
become millionaires dragging a reluctant
spouse behind where the wife is super
competent and confident with money but
her husband doesn't care and she just
drags him along or vice versa
where the husband's got everything
together and he's dragging this princess
with him you know it doesn't work these
are two grown-ups that are working
together making decisions together
that's what
data points tell us there was that
Sharon's in my experience too I mean
growing up sometimes fight we bout kill
each other sometimes but you know have a
good hillbilly fight right but but we at
least communicate and we haven't we have
a rule C when I went broke the first
time I can I was like the guy with the
bass boat I bought a whole bunch of real
estate and Sharon kept saying you know I
got a bad feeling about this and I'm
like yeah you got a home wrecker your
home with the kids you take care of the
kids that's your job I got this business
thing I got this as I was driving my car
off the bridge right right and so I look
back on it I go you know she kept saying
Bridge out bridge out Bridge out and I
was list I wasn't listening right and
then I started learning these biblical
financial principles and here's a
biblical financial principle for you are
you ready proverbs 31 who can find a
virtuous wife for her worth is far above
rubies the heart of her husband safely
trusts her and he will have no lack of
gain a financial principle and all the
data points of millionaire studies
indicate this a good financial principle
is that people learn to work together
with their spouse and men listen to your
wife sometimes when she has a feeling
that's actually God saying don't do it
stupid
now sometimes she's just you know had
bad pizza she's like anybody else right
but sometimes she's just a fraidy-cat
sometimes she's got a feeling and it's
called wisdom and so Sharon and I do not
do large purchases make big decisions
including large gifts in our charitable
giving that were not in agreement on if
I'm really kind of got a spot for weak
spot for these people in this situation
I think this is a good thing sharing
those you know I just don't feel good
about those folk then we don't give in
you know if we both have a vote in case
of a tie we don't and so she's like I
really want to do this trip and I'm like
you know I don't feel good about this
trip and we don't go when in doubt don't
and the two of us are in agreement when
one of us violates that it costs us
money almost every time or sorrow the
blessings of the Lord have no sorrow
added to them or about something and you
were really sorry you did it you get
home the next morning you go would I do
you buyer's remorse I can't believe
those a stupid I bought that thing you
know well you don't do that if you're
married and you have a virtuous spouse
now virtue involves understanding that
you're not you know you're not the holy
spirit that's not your job
it involves understanding and having
some humility with the discussion that
you could be wrong but you have this
feeling and you speak up and you talk
about the feeling so I don't feel good
about this there's all kinds of data
points but to say that that causes you
to win listen I quit doing it after I
went broke and it's not because I'm I'm
a wuss and not because my wife is in
charge of me or something like that it's
because I respect her opinion that much
and I think it's a biblical principle to
listen to a virtuous wife and so she's
not in charge of me I'm not a little
wimp or something like that but but when
she feels strongly about something I
really sit up and listen to that big
time every time I go against one of her
feelings it costs me at least 10 grand
so I just quit doing it I just quit
doing it and all the data points in
these millionaire studies and stuff
we're doing indicate the same thing as
going on with these couples that win
with money and what's interesting is
this stuff is inextricably woven into
each other - because Jesus said your
treasures where your heart is and so
when you agree on your money you agree
on your spending you're really agreeing
on and combining your value system
you're saying this is who we are as a
unified couple we have a marriage
mission statement and our values are our
core values are on the wall
even though you didn't write them there
but we're in agreement on those and
there's unity and I see that
consistently I mean you can't out earn
your stupidity and you can't out earn
your spouse's stupidity there's no
budget in the world no class in the
world that will allow you to drag
somebody who's bent on spending like
they're in Congress into wealth you
can't do it I mean and you know and I
think this is what causes people to have
such fights and divorces over money
because they both feel strongly about
one of them being immature and one of
them spending everything and one of them
being irresponsible and then the other
one is like mr. or mrs. responsibility
and grown-up and it just causes
unbelievable conflict so I it's such a
good idea to deal with marriage or deal
with financial issues in pre marriage as
well pre marriage counseling a lot of
people go through Financial Peace
University as part of the pre marriage
counseling because it forces you to talk
about these issues and it's the number
one thing in marriage and oddly enough a
quality marriage is probably one of the
top principles involved in it being able
to build wealth see how they're
inextricably woven into each other this
is real no boy with the bass boats
pretty funny line though this is the
Dave Ramsey show